[Musique]
jeudi 12 novembre
le soir j'ai eu plaisir d'animer en fait
le premier tlx à clé qui a eu lieu à
l'institut d'optique sur sur paris
saclay c'était un événement qui a eu un
vif succès peut-être c'est un organisme
américain qui a lancé l'idée dans les
années 80 c'est une série de conférences
soit sur une demi-journée ou une journée
ou plusieurs jours où on fait appel à
des intervenants
c'est généralement multidisciplinaire
c'est les intervenants ont des
interventions à faire entre 10 minutes
et 18 minutes maximum qu'ils sont filmés
en vidéo qui sont relayés et ses
interventions elle touche des
disciplines aussi variées que la science
l'art le design la technologie
l'entrepreneuriat et ce sont des sujets
généralement qui ont un enjeu société
énorme
face au succès des conférences ted aux
etats unis ils ont décidé de lancer des
licences au niveau mondial c'est pour ça
qu'il ya le petit x avec un nom de ville
les critères c'est d'avoir plusieurs
disciplines
on a commencé par un artiste après il ya
eu un physicien après il ya eu quelqu'un
qui a parlé d'une ovation frugal
en fait les thèmes sont vraiment très
différent des parcours différents
je vois tedx comme un pont entre
plusieurs disciplines contre paris
saclay et le reste du monde et entre
tous les acteurs qui veulent construire
des choses mais vous de paris saclay je
suis une passionnée de développement
personnel et je suis convaincu qu'en
fait cette connaissance de soi même pour
quelqu'un qui veut entreprendre est
vraiment clé apprenez à vous connaître
pour vous ouvrir à plus d'opportunités
plus de synchronicité et ouvrir créer
des ponts avec mes autres sur part
exactement t'ai dit que ce n'est pas
juste un spectacle où l'on vient pour se
distraire tedx c'est quelque chose qui
inspire pour pousser la personne qui le
regarde à aller chercher dans ses rêves
les plus profonds et à se mettre en
action et à y aller
si j'arrive à l'amener à tous les
habitants paris saclay j'aurais gagné
mon pari
[Musique]